مقطع فيديو جديد في غرفة الأخبار لدينا في هذه
الساعة يُظهر إعصارًا ضرب للتو
ساحل المحيط الأطلسي في فلوريدا،
وتقول خدمة الأرصاد الجوية الوطنية إن الإعصار
هبط في فورت لودرديل قبل الساعة 6
مساءً بقليل.  مع تحرك العواصف الرعدية القوية
عبر المنطقة وكان لديهم هذا
التهديد بالرياح والأعاصير الضارة التي
كنا نراقبها اليوم
بالطبع، على الرغم من أن تركيزنا كان على
الثلج، يمكنك رؤية المكان الذي
نزل فيه هذا القمع مما أثار بعض
ومضات الطاقة ربما في
حدث كل هذا في فورت لودرديل قبل الساعة 6:00 مباشرةً
وأصدروا تحذيرات من الإعصار لهذا، تم إصدار تحذير من
الإعصار
ثم شقت تلك الخلية التي تحتوي على نوع من الإعصار
طريقها بعيدًا عن الشاطئ إلى المحيط
الأطلسي، لذلك هذا هو الإعصار الوحيد
الذي لدينا  لقد خرجنا من هذا النظام
وهو الأول من عام 2024 ونحن في شهر يناير، لذا
فهو أول إعصار لنا هنا هذا العام